here with reaction from the Trump
organization Eric Trump is with us you
know there there hasn't been well first
of all in Iowa there was never there's
never been a person that won by a larger
margin than uh Bob Dole which was 1988
and that margin I think was 12.8% your
father won by by 30 points in Iowa your
father comes back and and does something
that hasn't been done since
1976 he wins Iowa then goes on to win
New Hampshire and he wins it by double
digits in a state frankly whose system
of voting in primaries I don't like I
don't like open primaries Republicans
should elect Republican candidates in my
view democrats should elect Democratic
candidates you can't deny these are
historic results for your
father there's no question about that
Sean frankly that's exactly why the
mainstream media is so petrified of him
it's why they go on and you know do the
Clips that you just showed right there
they're petrified of him he won the
largest margin ever in a primary in Iowa
as you just said the largest margin ever
in New Hampshire he he received
yesterday he received the most votes in
a primary ever in the history of New
Hampshire and by the way he's beating
Biden in every single National poll many
of them by 10 11 12 some 15% the media
is absolutely petrified my guy my father
is the greatest guy in the world he
wants strong borders he wants a great
economy he wants a strong military he
doesn't want to see this country go into
World War III he's sick and tired of the
N the games sick and tired of the
nonsense and I I think the enthusiasm
Sean that we're seeing all over the
place these massive turnouts is is the
American people who want our country
back they're they're tired of the worst
president in the history of this country
by far hands down it's not even close
they want a strong guy back in the the
White House and that's exactly what my
father will do and that's exactly who my
father is you know you you look at for
example the media uh this is now two P
well one caucus one primary in and here
you got Joe bid he he lies and says the
bord secure and the bord closed that's
not true it's never been true since he's
been president uh we can see it with our
own eyes he brags about bomic 60% of
Americans now live paycheck to paycheck
uh he lies you know I never one spoke to
my my son my brother or anybody about
their foreign business deals and he's up
to his eyeballs in it and yet here we
have a caucus and a primary your dad's
giving a speech a victory speech and
fake news CNN wants to fact check him in
real time msdnc wants to do the same
after they were excoriated for not even
taking a single word of your father's
speech that's NBC news now um what is
your reaction to that part of it because
we took your dad's speech uh it was in
my hour in this hour and and we ran the
whole thing so people can decide for
themselves uh what's your reaction to
how they handle
this well Sean does that shock anybody I
mean they've been censoring my father
since since you know the minute he went
down the escalator anything they put out
that he would censor right any any all
his press conferences they would censor
they would distort his words they kicked
him off of Twitter they kicked him off
of Instagram I mean any chance that they
could remove a public you know platform
for my father to use to communicate to
the American people they did does it
surprise you that msdnc is doing the
same thing on you know New Hampshire
primary night of course not does it
surprise you that CNN's doing the exact
same thing again Sean they're petrified
of my father and his message my father's
a one person who does not need this job
I talk about that all the time his life
would be exponentially better if he was
at Mar Lago if he's enjoying life if
he's enjoying his grandkids the guy
wants to save this country our whole
family wants to save this country our
our Republic is going down the tubes
based on pure incompetence and you just
mentioned the Border a second ago I mean
if Biden was so focused on the border
why does he have federal agents going
and cutting the barb wire to allow legal
immigrants into this country I mean why
would he be doing that right if he cares
so much about our economy why would he
have allowed inflation to hit 10% he
could have brought down gas prices my
father had the lowest gas prices in the
history of this nation the first thing
Biden did was he put a ban on the
Keystone XL pipeline he stopped all
drilling he effectively did a moratorium
on oil and gas and guess what inflation
shot through the roof and inflation was
was massively outpacing wage growth in
this country which was cramming down the
ordinary people in this country he was
making their lives exponentially harder
if he cared about the economy why would
he have done that it's Reckless this
guy's policies are Reckless it's driving
our country into the ground we're not
perceived as strong anywhere in the
world I mean literally other countries
around the world we have properties in
some of these countries They're laughing
at us they're laughing at the United
States of America you have zalinski last
week that literally went to Switzerland
to try and negotiate peace wasn't that
always America's place in the world you
go to America to negotiate peace you
don't go to Switzerland you don't go to
France you don't go to these other
countries you know you come to America
but we don't have that standing in the
world anymore we're losing our currency
we're losing our culture we're losing
our freedoms we're losing our
constitution we're losing God in society
we're losing it all because we have an
incompetent human being in the white
house and we need strength again and my
father will do an unbelievable job he he
will get this ship back on track in
about two seconds
flat let me ask you this and I I've
talked to a lot of people today and
Nikki Hale is not even competing in
Nevada Nevada and I'm not really sure
why
uh I apparently I guess she didn't file
the right paperwork something happened
I'm not sure but then the next state
that they will compete in is her home
state of South Carolina currently the
real clear politics average has your
data by 30 points um is it even really
worth your dad's time to engage in that
part of the primary uh and maybe it's
time to Pivot and really go after Joe
Biden well listen I think you can do
both at the same time and I thought it
was funny I standing right behind my
father last night and she mentioned
competency yet she lost by what 30
points in in the first she came in third
and in in Iowa she lost decisively last
night in in New Hampshire she filed the
wrong paperwork so she's not going to be
on the ballot next week so my father's
going to go running away with Nevada and
then he's G to go beat her in her home
state of South Carolina by lot and I
don't think there's a single elected
official in the state who's actually
endorsed her which tells you probably
everything you need to know about the
actual person so I think my father can
do both I mean he's clearly going to win
Nevada he's clearly going to win South
Carolina and I think he's going to win
every single state on super Tuesday in
fact it's upsetting to me Sean because
at this point I I truly believe that
she's just in the race to be a spoiler
and when you see the majority of her
donors are are Democratic operatives or
frankly rhinos I mean look at the same
person who's one of our largest donors
is the very guy who's funding many of
the lawsuits against my father right now
so many the things he has to stay in New
York and fight every single day Reed
Hoffman does that surprise anybody does
it surprise anybody that 70% of the
people who voted for Nikki Haley
yesterday were not Republicans they were
Democrats and some Independence I mean
Sean at this point I I truly believe
she's in she's being paid or something
to be in the race as a pure spoiler and
the you know the party should not put up
with that you know we need to focus our
guns Jo she has to win for for her to be
competitive and and so far that's not
going to happen and you know she can
overcome a 30 point deficit in South
Carolina uh that would shock me uh your
dad has the current governor the sitting
Governor two sitting Senators most of
the Congressional Delegation and I read
somewhere a total of about 150 Statewide
officials that are endorsing him uh Eric
Trump great to have you back sir thank
you we appreciate it just don't like
her we appreciate you being with us
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else